[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to a special
wild card weekend edition of the squad
ride live in the bleacher report app
presented by draftkings i'm connor
rogers alongside my man greg ivory greg
usually you give away hoodies on this
show and maybe an nfl jersey gift card
or two but i know you got a lot up your
sleeve today let them know what you're
giving away
connor we're giving away a lot we're
giving away over a thousand dk dollars
we've got custom odds boosts from our
friends over at draftkings hoodies
jerseys and at the end of the show the
very end of the show so please stick
around to the end of the show we're
giving away an iphone 13 connor yes an
iphone 13 i don't even have an iphone 13
counter do you
yeah i just got one greg and i'm gonna
be paying that bill for a long time so i
think that's the best giveaway you could
possibly have for the squad ride show
today i'm excited for that
that's a lot of good stuff so you're
going to want to hang around you're
going to want to be in the comments
you're going to want to give us your
locks takes i don't care whatever you
want to say get crazy in there let's
have some fun normally this is the time
where we share our favorite lock legend
videos from last week but today we said
it already it's a special occasion we're
going to do things a little differently
let's look at our favorite lock legend
videos from this regular season
[Music]
my props just finished cooking up
these are sizzling this guy's crispy
what i've stolen from vegas is the block
of the century it is happening this very
weekend
[Music]
who's doing it for us this week come on
buddy
buttercup's going to give us a lot but
he's coming back with the green ball
looking like super tough kind of sun god
let's go you guys have got to see what i
just pulled in
lock it in count on him to rumble in for
at least one this week ride with the
squad and cash your tickets
we got buttercup we got atlas all kinds
of legends in the montage this week and
that's not the only thing we're
switching up usually this is the show
where we ask you every single week who's
getting in the end zone who's gonna
score a touchdown but with our friends
at draftkings we're switching up the
odds booze this week we want to know who
is throwing for the most passing yards
on wild card weekend and here is the
odds list right now we got dak prescott
at the top he is the favorite going up
against greg's 49ers grace complained
about those corners before so no
surprise here patrick mahomes and brady
even there stafford joe burrow at plus
750 you gotta love how that's looking
greg kyler murray and jimmy g plus a
thousand and then josh allen in the
tundra in buffalo against a tough new
england defense as the biggest underdog
that made the board right here so you
know the drill by now we have four
legendary picks to show you the last one
standing is our wild card weekend squad
ride leader let's get this thing going
no more time to waste
and you know we gotta bring in the
legends for a special occasion like this
you got w trammell kicking this thing
off let's see the choice w trammell
what's up vr nation i heard my copies
got the lot for the most passing yards
this weekend
prescott is the choice by our familiar
friend of the show plus 450 i like the
coffee legend there a lot greg plus 450
greg's gonna be here to boost that so
that can get a little bit more fun
but i think we have a new contender
making his debut on the squad ride it's
the real day day what do you got for us
what's up what's up vr band this is your
boy the real day day
lock sony passing yards this weekend we
gonna have to go with the men with the
plan
joe burrows lock it in it's time to eat
fellas munch up
the real day day the hat legend
loved the bengals lid love the pick greg
that's how you make an entry you only
get one first impression that's how it's
done greg let him know what we need i
want to know where you're feeling now
where your head is at on a pretty brutal
first matchup prescott and burro
i got you connor i got you what i need
everybody at home in the comments to do
is let us know get in the comments type
out dak prescott type out joe burrow let
us know which way you are riding i'll
hop in here on dak prescott i mean he's
the favorite i wouldn't i would say for
a reason conor the 49ers uh secondary is
ailing they're struggling in the
secondary uh struggling in the corner
department to be specific uh
so he has
he has a bunch of number ones that he
can be throwing the ball to conor but
let's talk about the game and how it's
actually going to play out i personally
think the niners who likes to run the
ball will take advantage of the cowboys
defense who been struggling to run i
mean to stop the run so i think the
niners are gonna go about the time of
possession uh i think they're gonna take
that approach to this game so that's
gonna limit dax opportunities
to score so our two half passing yards
so i
that just yeah that pick is just kind of
iffy for me but i do like the joe burrow
pick i do like the joe pearl pick he's
taking on the raiders defense that's not
scaring anyone we know what the bengals
like to do he has weapons jamar chase he
has weapon he has weapons connor and we
know what he likes to do we know what
the bingo's like to do i'm rocking with
joe bro which way are you
yeah i'm with you all the way greg i
love your point about the niners run
game possibly dictating this game and
maybe taking the ball out of dax hands
more than they're used to that has to be
a fear right we're not sitting here
saying that you know because of that the
cowboys will lose or the niners will run
away with it it's just an aspect of
possession time and you see it with it's
not just kyle shanahan their offensive
coordinator mike mcdaniel is getting
head coaching interviews for a reason
right now because of the run game
they've built
they've built that to be ready for the
postseason and because of their
limitations at quarterback and that's
going to have a trickle effect on dallas
and i'm going to keep it real with you i
just love the joe burrow pick i think
joe burrow is going to have a big time
day i love those odds at plus 750 that
feels like stealing i'm not saying he's
the favorite but i love that choice now
i know we got a very cowboys friendly
comment section there's nothing wrong
with that greg where are they leaning on
this one
connor
you know we do have a cowboy friendly
comment section i have kenny cube cute
vision is in the comments he actually
has a joe burrow gift here uh sitting at
lsu smoking a cigar uh so shout out to
you kenny you're walking away with a
hoodie i also see i also see some dallas
fans in here uh shout out to you mike
bowlin mike bolan is rocking with the
with the dallas cowboys uh maxwell
rexella is also in the comments rocket
with the dallas cowboys uh
connor i think it's time for me to make
a decision uh jay vargas jay vargas is
the last one who was rocking with dak in
the cowboys connor i mean the people who
spoke and it's back and forth in the
comments but i think i'm going to make a
decision dak prescott dak prescott
is moving on to the next round
dak prescott i'm not too surprised i
knew the comments would steer us a
little bit more towards the dallas side
always good to see old friend w trammell
coming in
with the selection but the real dayday
making a strong impression with joey b
we'll revisit that one a little bit
later round two
it's time to bring back a familiar face
we got the pro angler jb
coming in with a choice this week what's
it gonna be
what's going on vr vetting went to
starbucks this morning to get my coffee
and they're handing out locks over here
now
so we got
patrick mahomes most passing yards week
one of the playoffs locked it in
the starbucks barista getting in on the
action here greg going with patrick
mahomes at plus 550 just a hair
under dak prescott in terms of being the
favorite here gets a tough steelers
defense but the jeeps are getting a
little bit healthy right now
this one is another close down to the
wire choice here which way are you
leaning right now
ah
we already jumped in we already jumped
in about i already talked about dak
prescott but let's talk about pat
mahomes connor
he's gonna hopefully tyrese uh tyrique
is healthy but you know what pat mahomes
like to do he likes to spread that ball
around and and
move the ball up the field uh
so
i think i'm gonna rock with pat facing
that steelers defense connor
which way are you leaning
yeah i like my homes as well in this one
it's it's not one of those times where
the match-up scares you off and
why we made that the case for dak right
here mahomes is going to get his it
doesn't matter who they're playing what
matters is that tyra kills healthy
that's what matters to their passing
attack and you got kelsey who's kind of
turned it on at the right time you got
tyree kill healthy mahomes is going to
be ready to go i'm not saying the chiefs
go out there and it's 400 yards but
there's no reason that you can't throw
for more than what dak does this week
i think our comments are going to agree
on this one i think this might be enough
to unseat that where are they going
right now greg
connor i am in the comments and i got
hair attacks hair attacks as pat mahomes
uh spreading some ketchup around uh so
shout out to you hair attacks you're
walking away with a hoodie i got m kent
93 says patty mayonnaise is a lot
they're they're funny in the comments uh
but yeah the comments is rocking with
pat mahomes i got one more
dana dana
dana
dole
six
dana dole six has pat mahomes
swinging a bat hitting a home run so
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you are walking away with hoodies but
most importantly connor it appears
patrick mahomes is moving on to the next
round
mahomes unseen dak but he's still got
one more challenger as we enter into
round three the final round to decide
the squad rod leader not for an anytime
touchdown but for most passing yards and
we're gonna bring back end goldberg on
the show trying to steal this one at the
end greg are we gonna have an atlas
appearance let's see
what's up bleacher report we got atlas
back and he's going to pick this
weekend's most passing yards by
quarterback and the red ball we've got
tom brady and the blue ball we got josh
allen whichever one he brings back first
will throw the most passing yards this
weekend ready atlas
look at that he's got the blue ball it's
gonna be josh allen most passing yards
this weekend
atlas riding with bill's mafia in that
frigid frigid weather game up in buffalo
that's why it's plus 1100 for a reason
folks no surprise there so
we got my homes at plus 550 keep in mind
greg is going to boost the winner so
don't be turned off by the odds josh
allen a big time underdog
greg you've told me before you don't
like the cold does that mean you don't
like josh allen this weekend either
yeah connor i did tell you that i'm not
too fond of the cold and i hear that's
what it's gonna be
in buffalo
and uh the last time my thing is connor
the last time we saw josh allen taking
on that patriots defense in the cold
it just didn't just didn't look too good
to me it did not look too good to me so
i think i'm going to stick with my guy
pat mahomes here uh just stick to
something that i've seen before i've
seen pat go out there and sling it
plenty of times and uh elements will not
be a factor so i'm going to rock with my
guy pat which way are you leaning
yeah if it's not broken don't try to fix
it mahomes is one of the safest choices
in the playoffs to put up big numbers uh
no matter the circumstances right and
they are it's the biggest difference in
terms of spread match up there big time
favorites against the steelers even
though we like the steelers defense he's
gonna get his i mean i love the bills
and i like the bills even this weekend
to win but i just don't know if it's a
game that josh allen comes out and
throws for 3 40 3 30. there's
quarterbacks out there that are looking
much more prime to fill up the stat
sheet this week
greg i don't think this is going to be
as close as the final round usually is
but i've been very wrong before on this
show
where are the comments going to decide
the squad ride leader for wild card
weekend
let me see connor i got richie rich
richie uh hold on yeah richie 21 not
richie
richie 21 says mahomes is easy money uh
daytra datreon9
got mahomes as a gift flexin
shout out to you uh oh connor i got bad
sports takes in here i'm going with the
underdog josh allen he's gonna pop off
shout out to you uh one more d more five
two one d more five two one has patrick
mahomes flexing in the comments so
connor i'm gonna make a decision because
patrick mahomes it's flooding my comment
section
patrick mahomes is the winner of this uh
today's squad ride that's who we are
riding with today uh let me pull up the
graphics so i can show you guys so i can
show you guys what we
can do to the odds here uh you see it at
plus 550 poof
just like that yes now it is boosted up
to plus 750 and it's time right now to
give away a jersey and 250 dollars of dk
dollars i have i have
rc italy rc italy um
says patrick mahomes it's too cold and
windy in buffalo i love that take that's
exactly my perspective of it so i'm
gonna have you walk away with a jersey
rc italy and for
the 250 dk dollars i got i love ranch in
the comments sending good vibes and says
mahomes for 400 yards
we need that
we need the 400 yards today uh so
shout out to you you're walking away
with 250 dk dollars let's go baby and
shout out to michael bolling in the
comments saying i can't believe he puts
ketchup on steak uh that is taboo i hope
nobody around here does that good steak
does not need ketchup but holmes is the
goat right now you can do whatever he
wants all right moving on we gotta pick
these games greg it's time to get into
this money line match up uh every single
game we're gonna break down and we're
going to go no spreads we'll talk about
them but we're going to look strictly at
the money line this wild car weekend
this slate is absolutely crazy but
before that make sure you get on
draftkings because they got something
really really special for first time
customers who can place a money line bet
of five dollars or more during the post
season and if your bet wins you'll
receive
280 dollars in three bets in addition to
your cash winnings
right that's uh that's a pretty sweet
deal man what are you thinking
that is a pretty sweet deal connor uh me
and connor are gonna go
game by game and give you our favorite
money line pick so i need everybody
everybody get in the comments and tell
us what you think
because i'm giving away hoodies i'm
giving away jerseys and i'm also giving
away another 250 of dk dollars connor
and i know you guys want it i want some
of those 250 bk dollars that's a parlay
right there
yeah i was wondering how you and i get
in on that i guess we'll figure that out
after this show all right kicking things
off with the game that is
going to be starting not too far after
we're done we got the raiders going to
cincinnati and that's a pretty big
spread for a wild card playoff game here
plus six the raiders are looking at
we're talking money line right now and
man greg i look at this raiders team
it's been a roller coaster season for
them
a shout out to them for the adversity
they've dealt with it's crazy that
they're even in the playoffs but the way
things ended the way their regular
season ended that was an emotional and
physically taxing game where
they might have some tired legs going on
the road this weekend now they've proved
everyone wrong multiple times but
i j i like the bengals greg i even might
like the spread i liked it much more
when it was at five or five and a half
and six but for money line purposes i
think joey b comes out gets it done has
a big day i just don't know and you said
this to me before we got on the show
today and i agree i don't know if the
raiders can score with this bengals
offense that's what has me worried that
most what about you
yeah
same carter i'm gonna rock with the
bengals i just don't know what raider
offense are we getting today which
raider offense are we vented are we
going to get the raiders offense that's
clicking that's jelen that's running the
ball and passing the ball fluidly uh
that involving waller involving renfo or
are we going to get the raiders offense
that's you know taking sacks and not
moving the ball down the field uh and
and having derek carr check down uh to
to his receivers so we just really don't
know which raiders offense we're gonna
get
we know about that bengals offense and
what they do so i think
i'm feeling safe with the bengals money
line but look at the over
look at that over
take a gander at it but i'm rocking with
the beagles money line
yeah anything under 50 uh set as the
over i would smash that i think it could
be kind of a shootout and i think the
bengals could even be in position to run
things up all right what are the
comments saying about this one you and i
see eye to eye we're going bengals all
the way are they with us or are people
buying the juice that the raiders have
had to close out this season
i see bengals all in the comments i got
wattages water just says he got a joe
burrow uh buffalo wild wings gift wow uh
that's good content right there so shout
out to wattages you are walking away
with a hoodie
all right moving on we got two games on
saturday it's a great great feeling
we said it before we're talking about
the tundra right now the patriots have
already been in this spot this season
they're going on the road to buffalo
it's going to be cold it's going to be
windy shout out to the bills mafia that
always fills up that stadium no matter
the conditions right now the bills are
five point favorites we're looking at
the money line and we are looking at is
mac jones gonna actually have to throw
the ball in this game or are they just
gonna go run run run like their navy in
college football all right greg i'm
going to kick this one off here
i like the bills i like i even liked the
bill's spread when it was around three
and a half four and a half but money
line purposes only i'm rolling with the
bills mafia i know it's hard to pick
against belichick especially in this
spot and i get why people are afraid to
do it but i think the bills simply have
the premium talent at quarterback that
it's gonna take to win in the playoffs
and maybe mack jones gets there but the
way he closed out the season i'm just
not believing that right now maybe next
year maybe two years from now right now
i'm afraid of that
yeah uh connor
in fact
i told the producers i told the
producers i was rocking with buffalo
but out today i woke up and i saw the
weather that's going to be in buffalo
and that just brought me back to the
last time these two teams faced off in
cold weather uh that's when the patriots
they barely threw the ball and they ran
the ball the whole entire game
those memories are in my head and i see
the plus money connor so
and i we know who bill belichick is one
of the greatest coaches to ever coach in
the nfl i think i'm going to go over to
that plus money connor and sprinkle a
little bit on those patriots uh
that's who i'm rocking with in this one
connor
yeah i'm curious where the comments go i
mean we've seen this matchup go both
ways already this regular season so
great get into the handy dandy what do
they got going on over there
i'm in the comments connor i'm in the
comments i got uh
the life of smitty says patriots believe
in big mac connor the where there's a
bill
there's a way
i like that i get it wrong uh
i got officially ronald in the comments
says bill mafia he has josh allen
jumping through a table shout out to you
officially ronald um
i got one more one more enemy landon
false got bill belichick winking connor
landed foss got bill belichick winking
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with the hoodies uh
we'll see connor we'll see
all right all right moving on to the
sunday slate the one o'clock we got the
eagles heading down south to take on tom
brady in tampa now normally you think
florida greg you think sunshine you
think everything's all gravy it's
january it might not be cold but it
might be rainy down there and we know
that eagles top flight rushing attack
could make things interesting so
normally you look at this line right and
it's a big one it's been an eight and a
half it's it's now it's at eight but
it's hung around eight and a half almost
the entire week
they are big time underdogs the eagles
where i was
tempted tempted to take the upset but
you got to use your brain here i'm not
betting against tom brady who's a big
time favorite here in the first round of
the playoffs i think this game is going
to be closer than people think i don't
think the bucks blow him out like the
spread indicates but i will roll with
brady with the money line here are you
with me greg
yeah connor i think that's a pretty safe
one i'm gonna roll with brady in the
money line there uh i saw a statistic i
read a statistic that the eagles didn't
beat any playoff teams this whole year i
don't see that changing uh on sunday so
i'm rocking with tom and the boys uh to
put the smackdown on the eagles on
sunday
i'd be surprised i want to see the
comment section i'd be surprised if
anybody was feeling bold enough to go
eagles money line here although the
birds fans they are always loud and
proud with bleacher reports so nothing
would surprise me
connor i'm in the comments you know they
are loud and proud in the
in the comments uh d money d money's in
the comments saying go birds uh
shout out to you d money i also got
enderman in the comments uh he he he has
an eagles flying high shout out to
youtube uh you're walking away with
hoodies but
connor i mean
the the comments there they might think
the eagles is gonna win but i i'll come
on
tom brady
greg's not buying the upset and speaking
of upset got one of our closest spreads
of the weekend next it's greg's niners
going on the road to dallas and this is
only a three point difference right now
looking at the money line greg
this is the first upset i'm gonna pick
here i'm gonna roll with your niners i
know the dallas fans won't love that i
just worry about what the niners grant
we've said it over and over today on the
show i worry about what that niners
rushing attack can do to dallas to
control the clock control the game try
to take it out of deck prescott's hands
and the cowboys in big spots i'm gonna
be honest with you they're starting to
worry me a little bit this year so
shanahan's been there before i know with
jimmy g it hasn't been very inspiring
but i think they got enough talent that
they pull off a pretty shocking upset to
a lot of people here
are you are you rolling with your boys
are you leaning the same way
yeah connor i i'm going to rock with the
49ers uh
simply because of matchups the 49ers
like to run the football dallas defense
they struggle running the football
usually typically in nfl if you have a
team running over an opponent
that team usually wins the football game
so let's not think too hard here uh
let's just i mean it's been happening
time after time in the nfl if the team's
able to run the ball they're typically
going to win and i think that that's the
game plan that the san francisco 49ers
is going to have against this dallas
team on sunday so i'm rocking with the
90. yeah
i think it's going to be a big day for
debo samuel as well and that's not
really saying anything surprising he's
been
one of the top five players in the nfl
this entire year but i think the matchup
for him
is great we're going to get into that a
little bit later all right this might be
the most conflicted comment section we
have here greg i want to hear where it's
going this is an old school nfl matchup
with dallas in san francisco which way
are they leaning this is
this is an old school rivalry i got mme
says sf all the way deepo will carry the
49ers shout out to you mme uh i also got
b hawk 28 says the niners officially
ronald is in the comments against and
niners up said uh
we the best 24 this is the great the
best thing niners gonna win by by three
late game drive by jimmy g calling it
right now
shout out to everybody that i said
you all are walking away with hoodies
i love that tape though conor i can see
that actually happen
a little belief in jimmy g that's uh
it's nice to see that honestly the man
has taken i know he's had his ups and
downs the man's taking a lot of hate
this year all right on to the
arguably but on paper it's not the
biggest mismatch of wild card weekend
here we got the chiefs and the steelers
the steelers tend to always hang tough
no matter the situation but there is no
denying this spread is an absolute
monster for a playoff game it is
borderline
disrespectful greg it's almost two
touchdowns
steelers and 12 point dogs against the
chiefs
this is gonna be chalky i'm taking the
chief's money line in this situation i'm
not trying to reinvent the wheel i do
think the steelers cover i did place a
real bet that the steelers cover at 12
and a half i'm sure this line has moved
a little bit but man i don't think we
can overthink this one right
yeah not let's not overthink this one at
all
um i'm rocking with the chiefs here
connor in this and this one uh
big ben he took the podium earlier in
the weekend
i don't know if he was pulling her leg
but he said that the steelers shouldn't
be here and
he's honestly he's right they they
shouldn't be here they got lucky last
week with with with uh the raiders
pulling it off at the end there um but
i'm just not i'm not yeah i'm not
throwing the curve ball here connor i'm
not gonna try to be superman and pick
this big money line uh play first no i'm
just gonna play it smart i'm rocking
with pat mahomes and them boys
yeah don't be a hero greg we got any
heroes in the comments right now anybody
bold enough to say the steelers are not
going to cover are going to
win
let me see
let me see i got a steelers fan his name
is steve s
s
roadock says kc moneyline steelers cover
jj oh i'm sorry tj watt for one and a
half sacks okay i like that take that is
a good take uh
there's not too many okay i got another
steelers fan saying let's go steelers
they're gonna clutch it up fl sports 13
shout out to you um but then i got john
briggs says chiefs will win this game
and will and will cover the game
stealers don't stand no chance they
shouldn't even be in the playoffs when
the holmes will ball
so they're back and forth in the
comments connor they are back and forth
in this one i'd like
i think i'm feeling pretty confident in
pat mahomes taking care of the students
yeah it's not the game we asked for but
it's the one we got thanks to the
raiders kicking that field goal all
right final match up and it's not even a
part of the weekend we got monday night
football
in the playoffs here
arizona going to la to take on the rams
another tight one another one much like
san francisco and dallas where this
spread is extremely extremely close and
man greg this is one i've gone back and
forth on for a long time here only a
four point difference
now i think this game is going to be
close i would not take the spread either
way and if i was i would take arizona
but for moneyline i'll roll with the
rams just by following my rule of
arizona at this point to me is basically
the chargers of the nfc where until i
see it i will not rely on you i like
kyler i really like cliff
but they just haven't done it in that
big spot yet and the same could be said
about matt stafford there's no denying
that but you can't say that about sean
mcvay the man went to a super bowl
before even turning like 35 years old so
this is a tough one i think it's going
to be a difference of a field goal or
less but money line i'll take the rams
because they're veterans in mcveigh as a
coach aaron donald and jalen ramsey
greg where are you on this one this is a
tough one
this is the tough one connor this is the
to me this one's a coin flip and i'm a
little biased because i'm going to be in
arizona next week and i mean hopefully i
can check out a game in a nice
atmosphere so uh
i think i want to lean arizona here you
mentioned uh
you mentioned matt stafford you
mentioned sean mcvay matt stafford did
not look good in that second half last
week conor he did not look good against
the 49ers he also needs to prove himself
you talk about the cardinals proving
themselves i think matt stafford needs
to prove himself in the playoffs in the
playoffs he got to go win the game he
has to show me something uh but i like
this cardinals offense i like sean i
mean i like cliff kingsbury and i also
like the quarterback out there
no d-hop that one hurts but i think that
they can get it done in this divisional
matchup connor you got to remember this
is this is their third time playing this
year so a lot of adjustments will be
made i like the cardinals in this one
all right all right greg we only
disagreed on two picks only two games
out of the six so let's make this
interesting for the people let's take
all our picks
turn them into a parlay and i'm gonna
cut you a deal right now we're gonna
take okay
bill's pick on my end because i cannot
being a new yorker pick the patriots i'm
sorry i can't do it okay i cannot do
that
by law but i will okay you in the middle
and go with arizona are we good with
that
yes we are good with that because i am a
bay aryan i am a bear and i cannot pick
a team from la so we we can we can we
can get along and we can go with that
parlay if you give me arizona uh we can
take the bills
all right let's let's take a look at
that uh that parlay in a bit and i know
greg you still got more giveaways to go
to here where where are the people out
are they gonna ride with us on this one
uh connor let me see i am in the
comments i'm giving away a jersey and
i'm also giving away some dk dollars uh
here we go i'm in the comments and i see
i see fl sports 13 he said let's go rams
they're going to destroy the cardinals
okay
uh that's not going with our parlay
cardinals is easy money hold on hey the
comments is jumping the comments is
jumping connor i'm trying to go back to
go find that one that i saw all right
here we go big mike 13 says cardinals
easy money win some dk money good play
off weekend shout out to you big mike
you're walking away with a jersey connor
the producer is telling me the aryan
giveaway the 250 dk dollars so look it
uh
i got
i got i got
sal
sal kamari sal kamari is in the comments
and look at connor he he he's throwing
he's throwing bad vibes in the air but
guess what i turned bad vibes into good
vibes that's what i do he says the rams
because arizona is inconsistent guess
what i'm sending you 250 bk dollars to
do whatever you want to do with it but
i'm sending you goodbyes because that's
what we need today we actually need
arizona to beat the rams so uh
a little reverse psychology right there
connor just a little bit of reverse
psychology and putting some good vibes
into the atmosphere
i like it man and i know for all those
in the comments going crazy that they
didn't get a maybe hoodie a jersey dk
dollars got an iphone coming up we got a
lot more in store so do not go anywhere
we've got some locks to give away as
well so shout out to everyone in that
comment section don't forget to get on
draftkings said it earlier five bucks to
win 280. for for first time customers
new users uh that's the deal of the
century so lock your money line bets in
this weekend
before we get into some player props
though and there's the new deal that if
you're not on draftings by now i don't
know what you're doing or have you have
your girlfriend sign up whatever you
want to do be a new user get in on there
okay before we get into these player
props
greg
we have some air pods to give away don't
you yes sir that is right connor earlier
in the week we asked you guys on the br
betting stream in the br app
what's your best money line bet for this
weekend after going through all the
comments connor after going through
every single comment we decided that
snoopy 25 no actually snoopy 2153 was
the winner let's take a look at their
money line lock there it is he says
brady plus playoffs equals bucks money
lying i like that a lot this week so
it's some juice but i but i think that
it is a lock uh connor do you think that
this is a lot brady plus the playoffs is
buck's moneyline i was saying earlier i
really wanted to take the eagles but i
have no problem with this pick okay it's
moneyline it's brady he's home he's in a
home game yeah i'm with snoopy all the
way snoopy deserves those airpods that's
a good take you don't pick against brady
in the opening round that's just insane
i don't care if he's 70 years old you
absolutely do not do it so
congratulations to snoopy uh vr betting
is sending you a pair of airpod maxes
pretty sweet deal if you ask me we still
got more hoodies got more jerseys we got
the dk dollars iphone 13
iphone 13 to give away so keep it up in
the comments and it is time
for one of my favorite segments that we
do here greg is prop block or drop it if
you like the prop lock it if you hate
the prop throw it in the trash drop it
right okay greg let him know what we got
six on the table get into it let him
know what we got
we got six on the table hey we go keep
this short sweet and concise what y'all
need to do in the comments is just let
us know if you rock it with the ogre or
the under it's pretty simple let's get
right to it connor the first one
we talked about the bengals taking on
the raiders it's in a couple minutes
actually
jamar chase is sitting that 71 and a
half
receiving yards connor i am going to
rock with the over here the the raiders
defense do not scare me one bit and we
know what the bengals offense loves to
do they like to push that ball down the
field and they also love to feed jamar
chase which way are you riding are you
rocking with the over are you rocking
with the underneath
rocking with the over all day this is
your
rookie of the year right here he's been
a total stud he's the best wide receiver
i've ever evaluated in any draft and
he's lived up to that hype every bit
he's gonna let he's bigger and brighter
when the moment is bigger and brighter
okay great he won a national
championship when he was 19 years old
with joe girl what do you think these
two are going to do on the playoff scene
right now jamar chase over he'll get to
72 plus yards
shout out to my man jamar chase we need
you to hit that over moving on to the
next one stefan diggs connor uh i i
strongly believe since the beginning
every time we mentioned stefan diggs and
the buffalo bills i was riding with them
showing them mad love it's still love
connor it is still love
but today they're they're in the cold
they they are in the code you know how i
feel about the code connor i do not like
it at all and uh the last time they
played in the cold i i did not like how
the last time they played the patriots
in the cold let me be specific there the
patriots in the code i didn't like how
they were playing but stefan's sitting
at 70 and a half receiving yards connor
i'm gonna go under here i'm gonna go
under
because it's in the cold what what are
your what are you thinking
i'm with you greg i'm gonna go under i
like the bills today but i think they
they get josh allen moving on the ground
i think they get motor singletary
involved dawson knox
diggs'll have his right but he's got a
brutal match up he's gonna see plenty of
jc jackson one of the best corners in
the nfl who's about to get paid big time
money in free agency and like you said
it's the tundra it's just a tough game
to be airing it out and giving diggs 15
targets so i'm with you that i generally
don't like over props that much when
they get high like this and 70.5 yards
it's a lot against new england it's a
lot in the frigid weather i'm with you
going under
connor's going under with me uh let's
move on to the next name big name right
here rob gronkowski big time player
sitting that 58 and a half receiving
yards connor i'm going to rock with the
over simply because
rob gronkowski shows up when the lights
when the lights are on rob gronkowski
usually shows up for tom brady and uh i
don't see that changing
this week against the eagles so i'm
going to go with the over here connor do
you see rob bronkowski going over or
under his receiving yards
tomorrow i'm gonna go with the over greg
i think they they need them to right
that's what it comes down to it's just
opportunity and if godwin was out there
if a b was still out there i would stay
so far away from this one and this
number would probably be in the 30s or
maybe even around 40 42. the fact is
this is mike evans in the gronk show
right now and tom brady knows that tom
brady is a man of comfort wisely he goes
to what works when the biggest games are
on the line and that's been rob
gronkowski for a very long time it'll
continue to be gronkowski i think he
gets to that that's 60 total around
there
i like that connor we've seen it before
we might see it again moving on we're
talking about d beau samuel here bebo
salmon we're talking receiving yards
here connor receiving yards only we know
the line we know the niners like to use
debo out of the backfield they also like
to have them coming off the jet sweep
and they also line them up at wide
receiver but we're talking about
receiving yards sitting at 64 and a half
connor i'm gonna go with the ogre i'm
gonna go with the over
simply because a couple reasons trayvon
dicks trayvon dix is uh the star
cornerback out there for the dallas
cowboys he gives up a lot of receiving
yards although he has a lot of
interceptions he gives up a lot of
receiving yards look for the double move
kyle shanahan loves to pull out the
double move when it's least expected
also debo he is a yak guy if you guys
don't know what yak means it's yard
after catch
my guy he's one of the yak bros on the
49ers and he is the mvp of the 49ers
offense i think when divo goes the 49er
goes so
64 and a half i can see him doing this
on one two plays deep shot or maybe him
catching the screen and taking it down
the field connor what do you think are
you going over under here
i'm going over this is a great matchup
for devo samuel like you said with diggs
yeah he was a first-team all-pro corner
that's nice and fun he's had a great
year he's feaster famine 10
interceptions great the amount of yards
like you said greg that he gives up it's
a lot and you know what some defensive
coordinator is okay with that bend but
don't break style don't allow anything
when you get in the red zone that
doesn't apply to this prop evo samuel it
doesn't matter on the ground through the
air he's gonna have a monster day i
actually like him better as a receiver
today
rather than a runner and i think he's
going to do both against dallas but i
think depot i would take debo if this
was in the 70s greg i like the over a
lot
connor's liking me over i'm liking me
over uh we are rocking with the diva
over but let's talk about the next
person kyle connor uh tyreek hill
tyrique is he hurt
is he not hurt
if he's not hurt i'm rocking with the
overall i've seen it time after time
tyrique on the go tyreek on the slant he
tyreke on the cross i've seen it time
after time from patrick mahomes um
i'm gonna rock with the over
hopefully he's healthy connor which way
are you leaning
yeah i'm leading with the over as well
here for tyreek now this is one that i'm
a little afraid of but when it comes
down to something you and i always say
greg he's due he hasn't hit this marker
in a couple weeks i think middle
december was the last time
he had a big time game where he would
have gone over this total so he's due
this offense is totally different with
him that's what it comes down to they
are just a well-oiled machine when he's
on the field and that's not even as a
decoy that's because they utilize him so
this is mahomes guy this is how they've
won a super bowl before uh this is a
risky play but i'll take the over for
tyreek hill who's a big time postseason
player
this is risky counter is he healthy or
is he
not uh moving on to someone that i know
who is relatively healthy at this point
of the season it's cooper cup my guy has
been bawling all year connor his over
under for today
for monday i believe monday receiving
yards is 106 and a half
now connor this is a lot this is a lot
but it's cooper cup and i think last
week i was rocking with the cooper cup
over and this week i think i want to do
the same simply because this is matthew
stafford's safety blanket you mentioned
rob gronkowski for tom brady this uh we
can they don't have as many rings let's
not let's not go there in the comparison
but as far as in the safety blanket i
think that this is matthew stafford's
safety blanket and he looks for him
consistently if he's rolling right he
looks for mccooper cup if he's in
trouble he's looking for cooper cup if
he has time in the pocket he's looking
for cooper cup i'm gonna rock with the
over because i think in order for the
rams if they want to win or if they're
gonna win cooper cup has to have a big
game connor talk to me do you like
cooper cup to go over or under his total
receiving yards
at this point it's chaos to bet against
this man and but i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna go under just because it's the
playoffs and this arizona defense has
honestly over achieved in my eyes all
season i think they're well coached more
they're better coached than they are
talented which speaks volumes to that
staff and that tells me they're going to
do everything to
not wipe out cooper cup it's impossible
you can't do it but can they contain him
can in key moments can they say
beat us with anyone else but this guy
because we're tired of watching it we're
tired of enduring it
so i'm gonna go under here i still think
cooper cup has over 70 receiving yards
but i this is a giant total and he's
earned it he's he's been the best ppr
fantasy player this year so
this might surprise but i'll actually go
under for the first time in a while
conor's going under here i'm trying to
see what the comments are talking about
connor because i'm giving away
a jersey and i'm also giving away 250 dk
dollars okay i got officially ronald
says six for six
all over everyone he is riding with the
shout out to you officially ronald
i got c big b c big b says cardinals can
shut him down
watch i think they're talking about uh
cooper cup connor just for that i'm
going to give you a jersey c big b he's
rocking with conor talking about the
cardinals is gonna shut down cooper cup
you are walking away with a jersey
hopefully you go buy yourself a cooper
cup jersey uh here we go
we got al mendoza al mendoza says i'm
putting these props on the parlay and
look like money to me
thanks for all the vibes fam you know
what connor
i like that and you know i'm gonna send
him some good vibes and send him 250 dk
dollars man hopefully you can put a prop
on uh
put another prop bet in with that 250 dk
dollars so shout out to you two you are
walking away
with jerseys and 250 dollars in dk money
all right we still have so much in store
for you guys including an iphone to give
away iphone 13 giveaway is coming up but
first i had a chance to catch up with
giraffe king's very own johnny avello
for the inside scoop on the hottest
playoff markets right now take a look
all right now very happy to welcome in
johnny avello from draftkings johnny i
got to start off with an easy one here
since the playoff field was set who are
you seeing the most super bowl bets on
the winner the winner of the super bowl
who are you seeing the most action on
there
that's an easy one connor the packers
before the field was announced and after
the field the playoff field was set they
continue to draw money right now they're
sitting at uh plus 380 which is 19 to
five that's the lowest price they've
been all season um one other the team
the titans are also getting a nice
little push in the futures market with
the anticipation of derrick henry
returning and the bye week to enhance
their chances of getting them back
yeah no surprise there to see a lot of
action on the number one seeds coming in
especially those are still pretty fair
odds and you mentioned futures
out of the futures bets that you have to
win the super bowl what is the biggest
one you have left that is still alive
going into the start of the postseason
i remember a bet that came in that was
approximately about
hundred
118
thousand to win one point one million on
the rams at eight to one okay uh and and
there's a still there's a few others out
there that are very similar to that
all right so for the book your biggest
liability to win whatever would cost the
book the most and the smallest
okay well the pats are the biggest um
you know past has been taking money for
the last half of the year they're
followed by not too far behind in the
packers uh
and then the cards and steelers are the
lightest
liability
uh if you had the insight to play the
cards before the season started you
would have received a pretty nice price
but they started so strong and then the
price plummeted quickly as far as the
steelers most action's been taken after
they made the playoffs no one had any
faith in them prior to that that
surprised me the steelers fans are
always not to call them bias bettors but
they are like the cowboys where they
come out large all right the last one
for me
we know it firsthand as we've dealt with
here on the squad ride had a lot of fun
with it draftkings has offered a lot of
new different props this year what is
the most popular new market that you've
seen this
year oh by far the same game uh parlays
they were the biggest a monster oh but
there were some others that also did
very well first quarter money line uh an
offensive score on the first drive of
the game
uh and that's a yes no type of prop and
another that was bet strong was the
player uh touchdown reception of x
amount of yards that's another one they
really love to play every week i know we
had a lot of fun with the no score first
drive on this show every single week
it's good to see everybody followed suit
with that johnny avella from draftkings
thanks so much for taking some time
today you're welcome connor
all right good stuff from johnny as
always giving you the inside scoop of
where everybody's laying the money right
now at this point and obviously
everybody's on the packers everybody's
loving those same game parlays but one
market you and i have loved all year
craig we talk about it every sunday for
monday night football is that no score
first drive and if you like yes the no
score first drive this is the godfather
week of it because right now draftkings
is boosting it for all six games this
week you heard me correctly all six wild
card games the no score first drive is
boosted let's take a look at the odds
here greg we might as well get the board
up and show everybody what we're working
with for wild card weekend and you can
see
where they started and now they're all
at minus 125 and
man greg
you and i i think love that vegas
cincinnati one especially if burrow can
get the ball early there's no doubt
about that niners dallas could be a
little bit of a track meet as well
arizona rams could be one as well you
gotta love what the chiefs can do if
they get the ball but you worry about
the steelers
greg let them know what we got going on
for this right now
i need everybody to get in the comments
and tell me which no score first drive
is a lock i'm giving away hoodies giving
away a jersey and i'm also giving away
250
dk dollars to my favorite
commenters
all right back to the matchups here
let's talk about our favorite one in the
comments they could ride with us they
can go with theirs we don't care there's
no bias here ray's gonna be fair for all
these giveaways
i think for me
on this one greg
it's gotta be arizona and the rams right
because remember you don't just need a
touchdown you just need that field goal
i think those those teams have had extra
rest they're the monday night game they
got some fresh legs on offense ready to
go i think that's the boost that i like
the best where are you at right now
so wait connor are you going score no
score with that game
i'm gonna go okay so yeah i forgot we're
boosting the no score so for the no
score it's got to be bill's patriots
because it's the tundra i think that's
the least yeah right bro
that was that was exactly what i was
going to say you you took the words
literally right out of my mouth no score
first drive i'm rocking with the tundra
game new england versus buffalo i've
been talking about it all game conor
been talking about the weather all game
uh so i like that one for the no score
first drive and you know we getting it
boosted at minus 125 so i'm rocking with
that one
are you rocking with that one with me
i'm with you all the way i don't think
you need to overthink this one i think a
lot of people would like the coin flip
of the steelers and chiefs the fact that
you know if the steelers get the ball
kansas city's defense kind of been up
and down but if the steelers get the
ball they don't really come out firing
but greg i mean let's be real you just
go with the conditions in this one it's
got to be the patriots and bills are the
comments agreeing are they all siding
with that
the elements are definitely a factor i
got uh i got three eats 77 says bill's
patriots it's too dang cold for points
tonight shout out to you you're walking
away with the jersey i'm also giving
away 250 dk dollars please explain how
the nfc east will it still gets
disrespected when we see when we send
two teams to the playoffs that's bg 73
vg
i don't know how they are getting
disrespected but guess what i'm not
disrespecting you because i'm sending
you 250 dollars of dk money that you can
possibly turn that frown upside down and
put a parlay in you know what i'm saying
you see how we do that here connor see
how we turn the negativity into
positivity bad vibes it's a good vibes
shout out to you uh vg73 you're walking
away with the dk dollars brother even
the angry commenters get rewarded every
now and then on the squad ride hopefully
coming back
with some better vibes and we'll
continue to look for those as well
because it is greg and i's favorite time
of the show it is boldest bets we're not
looking for the minus 125s the world or
the plus two hundreds here all the time
we're looking to get bold we're looking
to get crazy
and you can still win here without
betting on our boldest bets because greg
i know what you're giving away during
this and what they gotta do
connor i am giving away i'm giving away
hoodies i'm also giving away some
jerseys and i'm giving away them dk
dallas 250 of them to be exact uh so we
we connor let's just get right to it bro
let's not even play with them let's just
jump right in
who you rocking with what's your boat
has been
greg i know you like this one because we
were thinking the same thing here this
is the joey b special right here the
joey b same game parlay special joey b
going over
304.5 passing yards joey b with three
plus passing touchdowns for plus
500 that is juicy you said it at the top
of the show greg you do not trust this
raider secondary we like the bengals
offense it's just the borough special
right here at plus 500 this is a hail
mary that's worth it where are you at
this week
i like that connor i like that one a lot
i actually had joe burrow uh bowed his
bet
then
the producers was like connor has joe
burrow so i said you know what let me go
to the vault let me go to the vault and
dig up something else
so uh tyreke hill travis kelsey
to combine for over two and a half
touchdowns connor so that's i need three
between the two of them
i'm praying that my guy tyreek is
healthy if he's healthy i feel really
really good about this one connor if
he's 100 i'll feel really good uh but
i i i feel good i think i we know what
the chiefs like to do they they like to
feed their playmakers and these are two
of their biggest play makers on the
offensive side of the ball that patrick
mahomes feeds consistently so uh if if
he just does the same thing that he's
been doing
hopefully this can hit and uh but this
is what i'm rocking with today connor
i'm rocking with tyrique and travis
kelsey to give me three touchdowns
combined i like it greg and i think
you're looking for maybe you might get
two from kelsey i mean they love that
pitch play with him at the goal line we
know what these guys can do with the big
plays uh these are fun and our odds are
almost the same i'm looking at plus 500
you're looking at plus 450 we went bold
for wild card weekend is anyone crazy
enough to ride with us or throw in their
own boldest bets into the fray this
weekend what do we got
d money is in the comments saying i'm
rocking with that burro special
gave you a sunset
emoji with a lock and a money bag shout
out to you you're walking away with the
jersey for that one d money uh i also
also have
john briggs
uh oh this is a bowl take here connor
this is a ball take he says raiders
money line is a lock everybody is on i
got raiders money long and renfo to
score
plus 550 take it to the bank rimfo is
the best route runner he is going to get
in the end zone
and
he's going to get in the enzo had two
touchdowns last week come with the 2k
250 dkg money guess what my boy john
briggs you were walking away with that
250 and dk dollars brother uh don't go
nowhere don't go nowhere because i'm
about to give away an iphone
in the next segment
that's right man is it even the playoffs
if we're not talking futures we're
already looking ahead and we're asking
you
who's the best bet to win the super bowl
it's as simple as that that's what
everybody's got their eyes on for this
one so let's take a look at the current
championship odds to do exactly that as
you see the packers
johnny said it they're the favorite
they've been the favorite a lot of
betting slips coming in big on the
packers no surprise the chiefs after
that and then you've got a wide array of
teams that are pretty even with the
bills bucks titans and you get into the
world of the rams in dallas kind of big
time underdogs there so greg you've been
holding on to that iphone for a long
time i think it's time to finally let it
go
yes sir i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me
who
who's your locks are to win the
championship
if your comment matches the team chosen
by
the prize will
you
can win an iphone 13 connor that's how
they're going to do it
let's not keep them waiting anymore it's
time to spin the wheel right i want to
see this we've heard all about this
wheel
i want to see who who it lands on who's
winning who's taking it home here what
do we got greg
let's do it if your pick matches the
wheel you could win an iphone 13 the
wheel is spinning
and there it is
there it is uh it's the packers the
packers are the winners connor um
let's go to the comments let's go to the
comment
let's go to the comments uh i i'm gonna
read the comments i'm gonna read the
comments with the rockaway thing connor
i wanna talk about who you think is
gonna win the super bowl uh i got
packers is all in the comments q beast
800 says packers shout out to uq beast
uh
i think that's it bro
i think that's it obese actually obese
800 i think i'm gonna call it connor i'm
gonna give him the iphone right there
just like that he called it oh beast 800
you were walking away with the iphone 13
connor talk to me
who do you think is gonna win at all
connor
the man earned it uh you don't have to
you know be afraid of going with the
favorites sometimes and i think that's
the packers and plus 380s not crazy
let's be real they're telling you that
this is a wide open playoff field with
those odds nobody's even below that 300
marker so i like green bay i have a
ticket on green bay it's only going to
go up uh they are getting healthy at the
right time rogers is obviously on a
different level right now devonte adams
is the best wide receiver in football
and like again i can't say it enough
defensively they are getting their stars
back and adding to a defense that has
been so good while dealing with injuries
so i love green bay nobody wants to play
at lambeau this time of year guess what
you're gonna have to because they're the
number one seed so
where are you at greg best uh super bowl
futures bet here where are you riding
i i i i honestly i have two connor i
have two one as a fan and i'll explain
why i think the 49ers but i also have
green bay i also have them i think that
they came out this year and they they
showed everybody they showed everybody
what they are uh aaron rodgers looks
great he looks great um you mentioned
the home field advantage that they have
at lambeau that's big connor a lot of
teams don't want to go and face them at
lambeau in the tundra like you like to
call it in the cold uh so i like the
green bay packers but let me talk about
the san francisco 49ers and the reason
why i put the future in on them a couple
weeks ago connor they are a team that
likes to run the football and in the nfl
historically if you have a team that
likes to run the football
uh majority of time if they are
successful in the game they usually win
the game also you mentioned
them getting healthy the 49ers they are
also that defense have gotten healthy
they've gotten healthy at cornerback
they've gotten healthy at linebacker
that defensive line have they have
gotten healthy so
they're getting healthy at the right
time um a lot of teams they might not
say but they don't want to play this
49ers team they're actually one of the
hottest teams in the nfl in the latter
weeks so uh
i i like both of those i like the 49ers
and i also like the green bay packers
sprinkle some futures on both sprinkle
some futures on both
and you know what greg they've been
there right they've both been there so
you always ride with experience in the
postseason i don't mind those picks at
all with the packers all the way do you
think san francisco we're gonna see a
little bit of an upset this weekend so
that's a wrap thank you to of course the
lock legends that make this show so
great we had atlas returning from n
goldberg uh pro angler jb on his way to
starbucks as barista gave him a lock the
real day day making a great debut going
with the joe burrow pick which obviously
i am a big fan of greg is a big fan of
and of course the old school legend in
there w trammell pouring coffee in and
thank you to the commenters you make the
show that's what makes it special
hopefully uh you took something home and
if you did vr betting is gonna dm you in
the next 24 to 48 hours don't forget to
view all of our custom boost
the boost on the quarterback prop for
most passing yards that was patrick
mahomes you have a ton of options for no
score first drive jump in on the tundra
don't think there's going to be a ton of
points early in that game as they feel
that one out uh we have the five dollars
to win 280. i mean that's incredible
five dollars to win 280 in free bets if
you bet on a money line and hammer the
over is going on right now got
draftkings is wearing me out they got so
many different promos but hammer the
over this is a freebie here folks if you
bet on this one you're going to take
home some kind of money because they
keep dropping that point total it's
going down last time i looked at it
before we started the show was around 14
and continuing to descend up until
kickoff um for every 5 000 customers who
bet on that over market the point total
need in the game is reduced by half a
point so like i said now they're telling
me it's down to 11. this thing is just
gonna drop into the single digit numbers
please send us your reaction videos this
weekend and drop your real-time takes on
social and in the sports betting
community uh on the bleacher report app
and join us
next saturday we are back here yes same
time same place 2 p.m eastern greg has
tons of giveaways he's got all the good
stuff he's got the takes the hoodies the
dk dollars thanks so much everyone catch
you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you